Magnus saw a slower start in Poland a
much quicker one uh here in Zagreb you
mentioned that you love playing here in
Zagreb sum it up uh the day for us yeah
it was a very interesting day three
fighting games
um on another day I could perhaps have
eeked out so a win or even two more but
uh I'm I'm fairly fairly satisfied and
you started off with a pretty blazing
hot Victory against gookish tell us a
bit about gookish how do you see him as
a player after this point he's such a
young phenom
you know uh he's so young but I think
his play especially in faster time
controls is going to go up and down then
so right now he's he's struggling
um but I'm sure he'll strike back
quickly as
I think his General understanding of the
game is very original let's talk about
the game tell us where he felt uh you
created enough balance to yeah I mean
it's uh it's it's a line that's been
fairly topical for a few years
um and um yeah I was not so sure about
this Knight B3 move um
it's very concrete
which is the way you often often plays
but
[Music]
I I don't think it was was very good so
this was clearly the the plan to go for
I don't know yeah because all these in
all these lines I sort of need to take
away the C5 Square so I it's you you
often start in this these positions like
which moves I want to play yeah I want
to play B6 and then let's see if we can
make it work tactically I I felt more on
General grounds than anything else that
with his Knight on B3 I should always be
doing well here
um
I was not impressed here
uh I even had some crazy ideas like
taking here oh sorry not Bishop um
Bishop takes E7 and then going H3 as
much attacking the exchange
how do you deal with the Temptation uh
to play this type of role no I just
thought the alternative was pretty
awesome
um
but yeah here I played too quickly
unfortunately uh F5 was really really
weak
um for instance I could have gone for
Rook 88 and I just rejected the move on
General grounds because I'm just forcing
The Rook where he wants to go but then
just F5 and
I think I'm doing oh computer even says
I can go like there's nothing close
so that was a pretty serious misjudgment
actually and after Bishop G5 I oh uh I
realized what I what I'd done so I I
started to to spend a lot of time but I
didn't really come up with anything
um for instance if I go like Rook C8 now
I think he can go probably Bishop F4
uh if I take rookie 3 is coming and he
has got a pretty good
set up there so I didn't feel
comfortable so I decided to play for
activity and here he made a really
really poor decision
um he absolutely had to go Rook F1 which
is just also what I've been uh what I've
been focusing on this Rook C8 and it
felt to me that I was not risking much
but also
he's
um very much in the game here but from a
practical perspective you still felt
like it yeah it still felt like I was
okay but probably not really better a
while after the movie made I don't know
what he missed because he played it very
fairly quickly and my first thought is
doesn't this just lose to H6 uh and uh
after you know after thinking for a bit
that was my second and third thought as
well and now his Bishop is
first away
um
so I have this Pawn chain Rook C7 is
always met by Rook CA so it's from here
on I mean I took my time but it was
it was more of a mopping off job than
anything
yesterday you also played an important
event uh the all-encompassing title
Tuesday you finished on 11 out of 11.
how did that uh give you enough
confidence for today yeah for the rest
of the tournament yeah it felt really
good uh usually when I play those
tournaments I start off okay and then I
I tilt a bit at the end that I end up
with a pretty bad feeling and to be
honest like
scoring 11 out of 11 made me so excited
that it was hard to sleep afterwards so
I'm like I had I didn't really get
enough sleep for today but still uh yeah
I was was a fun was a fun feeling
definitely level out of 11 can keep you
buzzing congratulations Magnus we'll see
you tomorrow thank you